the president has been very clear even
when you asked him does a does a border
wall work he said no Secretary of
Homeland Security thank you he's just
such a peace I always get lost with him
because the eyebrows are so insane we're
not saying don't come we're saying don't
come now in right so he did that a
couple weeks ago and then now he's
saying oh maybe we should build a wall
or something like that but Biden saying
we shouldn't here's yesterday cringe
Jean Pierre on that the president just
told me that a border wall does not work
if that's the case why does his own
Department ofland Security Secret say in
a public notice quote there is presently
an acute and immediate need to construct
physical barriers here's what I can say
I can speak to what the president was
very clear in saying and also what you
all have been reporting about uh about
this uh uh this construction uh so the
facts are this uh this uh this is not
new uh These funds were appropriated in
fiscal year 2019 under Republican
leadership and DHS is required by law to
use the funds for appro appropriated
purpose that's what we're seeing this
was announced back in June by the DHS
and so look we we believe that there are
better effective ways of moving forward
to secure our border and security we our
Board of security and we have
continuously asked for congress uh to
act uh to provide our CBP of the law
enforcement uh law enforcement at the
border uh to give them the resources
they need to do their jobs and so we're
going to continue to call on Congress we
believe and the president has been very
clear even when you asked him does a
does a border wall work he said no uh
and he has been very consistent about
that we believe that we need a border
technology that is modernized and land
ports of at uh of land ports of entry
and that's what we want to see and
that's what I can speak to I love it I
love it we just don't believe walls work
it's funny because we googled it just
now every prison in America has a wall
because it keeps people in and it keeps
other people out by the way have either
one of you ever done fentanyl because I
just realized that she might be human
fenel because every time every time I
play a clip of her I actually just kind
of like slouch over and I just kind of
drool and like I can't really speak
while I mean Sarah everything with her
it's just like she should be studied one
day like the level of dribble right oh
for sure I mean it's agonizing but I I
almost feel bad for her because you
really have to believe just being Joe
Biden's press secretary has to already
be the worst job in the world and then
when you my sympathy gone well right but
then you factor in the fact that she's
completely incompetent to begin with and
then you're like there's no way you're
saving that um it's fascinating to watch
her say well we just believe borders
don't work I mean you had the President
coming out and saying I asked for
Congress to reappropriate that redirect
the that appropriated money to pay for
something else because I really don't
want a border wall is just so bizarre to
me you look at the national polling
National Security is polling as one of
the top issues for Americans not just
Republicans I think I read like 57% of
Americans put National Security at the
top of the list and so it's just so wild
to hear Kine Johan Pier say something so
off the- wall like borders do walls
don't work what do what doors don't work
locks don't work well what are we doing
in our houses locking our doors at night
if if none of these barriers work I mean
it's just so Preposterous to me and I'll
add one other thing Dave um she
mentioned in the first clip that you
played experts say experts say that that
border barriers don't work and I'm
wondering which experts she talk to is
this like a captain of al-Qaeda who's
like yeah border walls don't work
definitely don't put those up ft country
yeah exactly liby it's worth noting that
you are in a hotel today right asking
what I'm sorry it's worth noting that
you're in a hotel today right and
because you're in Miami you're in a
hotel right now does that hotel have a
door that maybe would prevent some
people from coming in and other people
does your room that you're in have a
door or any sort of barrier to the
hallway it does and you might be shocked
to know this but you need a key to get
into that door to actually access
killing and even once you're in the room
there's a lock on the bathroom door as
well even though I'm the only one here
so whoa um yeah I mean the security is
extra tight here in Miami no that
doesn't work that doesn't work
yeah